jim cramer the eccentric stocks guy from
cnbc
has had it with you
and your freedom and your prudence and
your legitimate moral and medical
objections to the fauchiachi and if
you're not going to comply
well then in his view
maybe it's time to take some more
drastic measures
lord knows what happened if you didn't
partake but back then anyone who refused
to get vaccinated would get ratted out
immediately because we knew that person
could hurt other people the common wheel
was
a common will
now we're engaged in a similar struggle
with covid and eisenhower would be
aghast we have immunocompromised people
who are incubators for every variant to
come
walking around lawfully unvaccinated
that's psychotic
we have companies that have tried hard
to get people vaccinated not backing
down we have governors who want to be
president by grandstanding on a foolish
state's right issue the right to get
sick and get other people sick
so it's time to admit that we have to go
to war against covid require vaccination
universally have the military run it if
you don't want to get vaccinated you
better be ready to prove your conscience
just object your status in court and
even then you need to help in the war
effort by staying home until we finally
beat this thing
marshall law
the cnbc stocks guy
is calling for martial law
to make you take the experimental shot
to protect against a virus that poses
very little threat to the vast majority
of people who according to the cdc may
very well contract and spread the virus
even after they're vaccinated
my hope here
is that jim cramer has just invested a
bunch of money in pfizer or something
and is working on an elaborate pump and
dump scheme but i suspect that's not the
case i suspect he's just stating his
honest views which i suspect are the
honest views of many liberals that is
that we need to suspend constitutional
government
the ordinary american way of life for 15
days or 15 months for a few years or
maybe just forever i'm michael knowles
is the michael all show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from crdp07 who
says pete buddha judge says
black people don't have the resources to
obtain a valid id
pete buddha judge also says black people
worried about gas prices have the
resources to just buy an electric car
that's that was his advice
mr secretary what what happens what do
you say to people who are worried about
the prices at the pump well just buy an
electric car it doesn't need to be the
tesla model x it can be the model s
that's only like 60 grand that's fine
all right that's what we can do but yeah
but right but black people can't
afford to get bus fare to go down and
get a valid government id but everyone's
going to buy a tesla is that ah it seems
a little disingenuous to me
all of this disingenuity all of this
dishonesty and insincerity it's enough
to keep you up at night
unless you have bowlin branch then
you're gonna sleep great this cyber week
bowlin branch is offering their greatest
deal of the entire year
if last night's sleep was not incredible
if you woke up you just thought i need
something a little better
bowling branches sheets will make all
the difference with bowling branch you
get the best sleep of your life with
their highest quality organic cotton
sheets bowling branch holds themselves
to high standards across the board not
just their sheets that are made this way
their pillows their bath towels their
robes are too the signature hemmed
sheets are their all-time best seller i
have gotten multiple
hem sheets i have bought them you know
sometimes i get freebies i have bought
them they are that good in my life i
have had the privilege on occasion of
sleeping in a really nice hotel you know
if i'm on the road or to give a speech
or something like that or when i can
steal the credit card from shapiro and
the big difference with nice hotels is
it's the bedding it's the sheets with
bowl and branch you can sleep on a
five-star hotel kind of bedding every
single night this cyber week give your
loved ones the best sleep of their lives
or treat yourself with bowl and branch
the christmas packaging famously soft
sheets blankets pillows and more will
make a difference that everyone will
feel get 25 off from november 23rd
through december 2nd with their best
offer of the year at bowlingbranch.com
get 25 off b-o-l-l and branch.com
exclusions may apply some good news on
the
vaccine mandate front
contrary to what jim cramer and cnbc and
all the rest of the libs want
we seem to be moving away from the
direction
of martial law and mandates and
lockdowns and taking away all your
rights another federal judge has just
blocked
joe biden's vaccine mandate
this was a federal district judge st
louis-based district judge matthew shelt
who is now
he's now stopping the mandate from going
into effect for health care workers in
10
states
those states are alaska arkansas iowa
kansas missouri nebraska new hampshire
north dakota south dakota and wyoming
when we talk about the vaccine mandate
it can get a little bit confusing and
you hear about all these rulings from
all these different courts that's
because there are actually multiple
vaccine mandates there's a vaccine
mandate for federal workers there's a
vaccine mandate for federal contractors
there's a vaccine mandate for health
care workers there's a vaccine mandate
for workers at allegedly private
companies with 100 or more employees and
so you've got to fight it on all these
different fronts and there are slightly
different mechanisms for all of these
different mandates but they're all
getting smacked down
just about every single challenge the
mandate that has gone up to one of these
federal courts has at least resulted in
a pause in a stay of the mandate until
they can sort out the legal issue you
know the daily wire is leading the fight
with the lead plaintiff in the u.s
sixth circuit court of appeals
that would be against the employer
mandate from osha but this is great news
for health care workers
last year health care workers were the
greatest heroes in the history of
america they were like the boys with the
flag on iwo jima they were the first
responders on september 11th they were
the most wonderful lauded people in the
world but then the minute they didn't
want to take the experimental drug for a
virus that doesn't pose a great threat
to a lot of people
all of a sudden they became
persona non grata you know and they were
they were
murderers and killers and irresponsible
and anti-vaxx
schmucks so
this is great news it's more evidence
that the mandate is unconstitutional
which we've been calling from the very
beginning and as i've said you know i
hate to say i told you so but from the
beginning i've said i think that joe
biden knows that it's unconstitutional i
think joe biden knows he doesn't have
the power to push these kinds of
mandates in this way
he almost admitted as much on the
campaign trail that's why he said i'm
not going to do a vaccine mandate i have
no no reason to do it but
with any reversed course
why because
even if the mandate is struck down in
the courts which it's looking
increasingly like it will be
doesn't really matter
because by that time
all the people will have gotten
vaccinated because their employers will
have forced them to or they'll lose
their jobs and so it's just a pressure
campaign and then six months later a
court rules and says no it's
unconstitutional and biden says whoopsie
daisy
oops
okay well never mind you already took
the fouchyauchi so deal with it he'll
get exactly what he wants speaking of
important court cases
there is an extremely important court
case
that that has gone up to the court today
the court is hearing oral arguments in
this case today
this is more important
than the vaccine mandate cases this is
more important than any other case
that's going to go before the court
this year
or in the next several years
it is dobbs versus jackson women's
health
this is a case about a mississippi
abortion law that could overturn
roe versus wade and planned parenthood
be casey
roe versus wade is the case that
established the fictional constitutional
right to abortion
planned parenthood v casey
uh uh held it up
capitol hill police expect up to 20 000
protesters
to show up to dc this morning
there will be pro-lifers there there
will be pro-abortion people there
this is uh expected to result in a
larger crowd than any supreme court
demonstration
ever
this is because
roe vs wade is
perhaps the single most unjust
constitutionally and legally incoherent
supreme court decision in history
there are some competitors for this
title
but it definitely can lay a claim to it
and a lot of our
current political dysfunction comes from
roe vs wade because regardless of your
feelings on abortion the simple fact is
there is no right to an abortion in the
constitution and even abortion's most
ardent defenders if they're being honest
will admit that it's just not there
and
in 1973
activists on the court decided that they
were going to invent this right to
abortion they were going to read some
invisible ink written in the
constitution somewhere between the
emanations and the penumbras and because
of that now every supreme court
nomination fight
is
extremely bitter you remember amy
barrett you certainly remember brett
kavanaugh robert bork i mean it seems to
me whenever there's a conservative judge
up for the court this is really
hideously bitter fights because the
supreme court holds an incredible amount
of power now because they're not just
interpreting the law according to their
prudence
and
according to the text of the
constitution according to case law but
they are now
making law in some ways
in in so egregious a way that it has no
basis whatsoever in the text like in roe
versus wade the the specific issue is
mississippi's abortion ban after 15
weeks of pregnancy
uh the the court
will address the question of whether all
pre-viability prohibitions on elective
abortions are unconstitutional so this
is before the baby can survive outside
the womb
and you're talking about
you're talking about an issue that will
cut right to roe versus weight because
roe versus wade forbid states from
prohibiting abortion pre-viability
the lives of
countless millions of people will be
affected by this decision
it will be life or death
because of this decision
and i'm not talking about the
the poor women who can't get abortions
anymore thousands of women every year
who died from abortions even though that
never took place that was a complete lie
from the pro-abortion movement and
actually one of the guys who created
that lie dr bernard nathanson he was the
head of neral the abortion rights league
he admitted that that was a lie
he said yeah that 5000 number we just
made it up the actual number of women
who died from back alley abortions the
year before roe versus wade was less
than 40 4-0
and and by the way
20 some odd women died of legal
abortions that same year and when you
look at the legality
by state by state of abortion in the
year before roe versus wade was decided
your likelihood of dying from an
abortion was basically the same if it
was legal or illegal
okay but the lives of 60 million babies
have been killed since roe versus wade
how many more in the future could be
killed or could be saved and
almost as important as that
the future of the conservative legal
movement
will very likely be decided by this case
the federalist society originalism
all of these
all of these movements that have
developed over the past
few decades more than a few decades now
on how conservatives are going to retake
the courts and reshape the law
if we don't win here
we've already lost so much we lost
marriage we lost the definition of sex
itself in the boss stock decision
we lost obamacare if we can't
overturn roe versus wade
then what is the point of the
conservative legal movement probably if
we can overturn roe versus wade we're
going to need
a new conservative legal movement
now
what you might need is a new interest
rate on your home which is why i would
strongly recommend you check out
american financing there is still time
to make a positive impact on your budget
before year end as mortgage rates remain
near money-saving lows now you might be
thinking why why my mortgage is just
fine as it is well i humbly would
suggest you you should be thinking
how is your mortgage going to work for
you
and that answer can be found at american
financing america's home for home loans
they give sound advice they don't
pressure you their salary-based mortgage
consultants get to know you
so they can lead you to greater overall
savings could be as simple as finding a
shorter loan term or consolidating debt
because there's more to a refinance than
just a lower rate and through this they
save customers up to a thousand dollars
a month that's a lot of money why not
see what they can do for you call
800-685-5696 that number again is
800-685-5696
or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
speaking of babies
the white house has just released its
christmas photo
so the biden white house christmas photo
showed a fireplace mantle hung with
stockings for six of joe biden's
grandchildren
it's very nice sort of elegant design in
the grand room six stockings wait a
second
joe biden
has seven grandchildren
but there's only six stockings there and
they've got all their little names on
there so it's clearly for the
grandchildren now you might say this is
just because joe biden's forgetful he is
very forgetful but i don't know jill
biden's not that forgetful and the white
house staff is certainly not forgetful
oh right one of those grandchildren
is illegitimate it was the grandchild
that hunter biden had with
london roberts who was a stripper
and hunter biden refused to acknowledge
the baby and then a court forced him to
take a paternity test and then it turned
out he was the father meaning joe biden
is the grandfather and joe biden refuses
to acknowledge his own grandkid
according to london roberts's attorney
neither hunter biden nor joe biden the
warm wonderful happy good old uncle joe
president
has ever seen the three-year-old
child
i really do not mean this as a cheap
political attack i don't mean this to go
after family or anything like that
not very much shocks me in politics
but i am genuinely impressed by the
cruelty of the president of the united
states joe biden
in refusing to acknowledge one of his
own grandchildren
yeah hunter biden's a complete
degenerate i don't expect anything of
him he's a crooked
degenerate
but what about joe biden
i'm not gonna i don't want to take any
cheap political attacks here at joe i
just think joe says he's a nice guy he's
a normal guy he's a devout catholic
right and he is cruelly refusing to
acknowledge one of his own grandchildren
the president of the united states
shouldn't that be a scandal
what is this kid going to think the
kid's three years old now probably
doesn't understand too much what is this
kid going to think
think it's a she i don't know let's just
say it's a she
i'll look at i don't know very much
about about the kid in navy's sort of
ambiguous name as so many are these days
but what is this child going to think
when she grows up
and is 9 or 10 years old
says why won't my daddy acknowledge me
why won't my grandpa the president of
the united states acknowledge me i'm not
good enough
i'm i'm a mistake i'm an accident i'm a
shame i'm a problem i'm a humiliation
that's a horrible thing to do to a child
that's all that is a genuinely horrible
thing that joe biden is doing right now
and i try to resist all the easy
political attacks on hunter biden even
though there are plenty of legitimate
attacks because he was compromising
national security he was selling
america's
influence around the world to the
highest bidder i mean there were a lot
of serious problems with hunter i try to
lay off the hunter stuff
but what joe it's not even hunter's
problem
so i don't have any expectations of him
what joe biden is doing here is
disgusting it's despicable it's shameful
it's extremely cruel and it should be a
national scandal and more people should
talk about it speaking of cruelty
twitter
has a new feature it's called twitter
spaces if you remember the app clubhouse
it's kind of like that where you can log
in and have audio conversations with a
curated group of people so twitter has
just rolled this out i haven't tried it
yet but i did see when twitter rolled it
out
that
there was a trend a trending hashtag
the trending hashtag was a hashtag
mayommonkey's gotta go i said mayo
monkeys what is it and then i looked at
what was next to it
yt people deserve nothing n-u-f-f-i-n
why t like youtube people well i agree i
do think they deserve nothing i don't
think they deserve anything
oh no it's white then i realized it's
white people white
people deserve nothing hashtag mayo
monkeys gotta go now i have always
considered myself more of an aioli
monkey i'm a little spicier and
mediterranean and very very
sophisticated but i think they were
using this term mayo monkey to refer to
all white people
take a listen to the conversation
first of all let's talk let me tell you
something if you're in here or y'all go
run back and tell them you only got to
tell them tell them that nobody else
said
but me i'm going to say listen you ain't
got to chop [ __ ] up i am for the white
genocide i am for the total erasure of
the white race i you don't have to chop
this up yes i am for all of you white
dying like flies i am for it i am for it
i support it i am for putting all you
white possums in a gas chamber and
letting that [ __ ] ring i am for
it so you don't have to chop [ __ ] up i'm
for it and i'm going to stand 10 toes
down behind it
simple as that so you got to chop [ __ ]
up you ain't got to screw this
i set it and i stand on it
now
lest you think that this was just some
kind of random
uh brief exchange from a co-host of this
conversation on twitter it wasn't one of
my producers was in the conversation
live when it was happening it was the
whole conversation obviously look at the
title of it white people deserve nothing
male monkeys gotta go this was trending
on twitter
[Music]
which it would seem to contradict the
lie that we're often told and now that
children are taught in schools across
the country that black people can't be
racist
you'll hear this taught in corporate
boardrooms in classrooms all over the
place
black people
can't be racist so even if they say
something like this they're not really
racist because they're black and if
you're black you can't be racist so by
definition they're not racist even if
they're calling explicitly for the the
white genocide they're their words not
mine and saying we have to put white
people in gas chambers
it goes without saying i hate to even be
so cliche as to say this that if white
people did anything like this it would
be not just a an incident on twitter not
just a controversy in the united states
it would be an international incident
the u.n would be looking into this okay
but it's not
and so
there is obviously a double standard
here and it's frankly it's not even
really worth i mention it just
so briefly for the for the handful of
people who don't see the point who don't
see the double
standard
contrary to the view that is taught in
schools and in offices and hr trainings
and comes from critical race theory and
other associated movements contrary to
the idea that only white people can be
racist
all of the evidence we have available to
us
suggests that white people are the least
racist people on earth they are the
least racist people ever in the whole
history of the world
pew research
had a survey that came out just a few
years ago
showed that white people have the lowest
racial consciousness by far they asked
people who are white black asian and
hispanic how important is your race to
you
and
of the people who said that race was
somewhat or very important
you had that number over 50
for asian people
over 50 percent for hispanic people over
70 percent for black people said their
races somewhat are very important to
them
only 15 for white people
shockingly low racial consciousness
there's another survey survey just came
out from rasmussen
that said that 37
of american adults
believe that black people
hold racist views
as opposed to just 15
who who believe that white people hold
racist views
now you might say well that's just
because i don't know there were a lot of
white people pulled but it's not true
even among only the black people polled
the black people believed that black
people were more racist than white
people 31 of the black people surveyed
by rasmussen said that they considered
people of their own race to be racist
while only 24 of them thought that white
people were racist so we're not saying
that white people are not at all racist
or that black people are completely 100
racist but all of the data we have
suggests that white people are the least
racist people in the history of the
world in fact
the very concept of racism the very idea
that racism might be a bad thing comes
from
white people
that's
just look at the history of the ideas
so
the idea that that only whites can be
racist is as
we see from social sciences we see from
various twitter conversations
perfectly divorced from reality
okay it's and you see this a lot in our
culture increasingly so
maybe the most obvious version of this
is that is transgenderism the idea that
men are really women and if you say that
they're not you're
you know you have to be silenced
if you contradict this obvious delusion
that is totally divorced from reality
but you see this on issues of
sex
race economics
politics
everywhere you are seeing a chasm
opening up
between the official narrative that the
establishment tells us
and reality
and this is a very
scary thing
because things do not end well when your
society is divorced from reality let's
take this beyond the racial issues and
the mayo monkeys having to go and the
sex even just broadly if your society
is grounded on
delusion
your society is not going to flourish
when you look around us right now and
you see society crumbling in basically
every
sector and you and you see the people
running our society have extremely low
approval ratings rightly so
you you see the consequences of that
delusional kind of ideology now
you probably in this crazy time
going to want to protect your money and
your future in your retirement which is
why i would recommend you check out alto
ira i was very skeptical of crypto okay
for many years i'm kind of a luddite so
i was very skeptical
i just got into it i just got into it i
couldn't resist and
when i get into crypto i want to make
sure that i'm doing it in the smartest
possible way with an alto crypto ira you
can trade crypto like bitcoin and avoid
or defer the taxes so you might be in
crypto already but you're probably doing
it in a very inefficient costly way
now you can get into investing in crypto
and do it in a tax advantage retirement
account alto's crypto ira is the easy
way to get crypto into an ira trade all
you want without the tax headache
you can create an account in just a few
minutes and invest with as little as 10
there are no setup charges you get
secure trading 24 7 through alto's
integration with coinbase 80 plus coins
available including bitcoin ethereum and
cardano
alto's industry-leading security makes
it safe there are multiple ways to fund
your account you can make a cash
contribution transfer cash from an
existing ra roll over an old 401k you're
ready to take your investments to the
next level diversify like the pros and
trade without tax headaches open an alto
crypto ira with as little as 10 bucks
join at altoira dot com slash michael a
l t o i r a dot com slash michael mich
ael start investing in cryptocurrency
today alto ira.com slash michael
speaking of delusion
you've really got to read matt walsh's
new book
head on over to johnny thewalriss.com
j-o-h-n-n-y thewalriss.com
reserve your copy of matt walsh's timely
masterpiece about a little boy who
thinks that he's a walrus
also if you have not already go check
out our new comedy series truth yeller
hosted by comedian podcaster adam
carolla over at dailywire.com watch in
each episode of truth yeller adam
invites a celebrity guest to join him
for an evening of stand-up comedy improv
and interview all in front of a maskless
live audience the first two episodes are
available now with the first episode
starring none other than
jay leno head on over and catch up on
our new series over at dailywire.com
watch today and enjoy we'll be right
back with a lot more
speaking of twitter
hipster rasputin
is out at twitter jack dorsey the
founder and ceo of twitter is out
i think he actually left the company
already once before and then he came
back well now he is out again
the new ceo is the current cto the
technology officer
parag
agrawal
and
as one does now when someone comes into
a position of prominence everyone's
digging up perrag's old tweets there is
one tweet that is really going viral
where he makes some comment about white
people and racism and he's really
quoting him daily show and
i think it's a little bit of a
misdirection i don't think that's the
most alarming thing that perag has ever
tweeted
i don't think it's the most alarming
thing he's ever said
there's a far more
unsettling clip that came from a podcast
that mr agrawal was on recently it's
called in machines we trust
in the clip
agrawal talks about misinformation
and his theory on how twitter needs to
combat the alleged scourge of
misinformation
who gets to decide what is a
misinformation can you give a clear
clinical definition of misinformation
does something have to have malicious
intent to be misinformation how do you
know if your credible sources are
truthful what's measuring the
credibility of those sources and someone
even saying i've seen misinformation in
the so-called credible sources so how do
you define that phrase i think that's
the the existential question of our
times defining this information is
really really hard as we learn through
time our understanding of truth also
evolves
we attempt to not adjudicate truth we
focus on potential for harm
and when we say we lean on credible
sources we also lean on all the
conversation on the platform that also
gets to talk about these credible
sources and points out potential gaps
as a result of which the credible
sources also evolve their thinking
or what they talk about so
we focus way less on what's true and
what's false we focus way more on
potential for harm as a result of
certain content being amplified on the
platform without appropriate context
there is the key
there is the key to all the bad stuff
that's about to come out from twitter
and all the bad stuff that's really
already going on at twitter and it's the
it's the heart
i don't think i'm overstating it it's
the heart
of
all the bad stuff that we have been
getting out of the left in recent
decades we don't try to adjudicate what
is true
we just try to look at the potential for
harm
this simple sentence which he repeats
it's not that he misspoke he knows
exactly what he's saying
that sentence
is at the very heart of our cultural rot
we don't want to find out what's true
we don't want to find out what's true we
maybe there's a skepticism there we
can't really know what's how are you
supposed to know what's true
a lot of people on the left have been
telling us that you can't really know
what's true there is no objective truth
the movements of
dairy da the movements of post
post-modernism the movements all
throughout the academy and all
throughout our society a lot of people
on the right have embraced this too
especially libertarians have embraced
this kind of talk well who's to know
what's good maybe your definition of
good is different than my definition
who's to know who really can adjudicate
truth we just need to
respect one another's boundaries we just
need to resp you do you i'll do me
we forget about what's true let's only
focus on what's harmful now
there's another really nasty premise in
here
which is that what's true
and what's good
might be totally different things
and and consequently what's false and
what's harmful might be totally
different things
in the traditional society
the good and the true and the beautiful
were considered to be united the
transcendentals
right
we what do we want we want what's good
and true and beautiful
but in the modern society that throws
all those crazy old ideas away from old
uncle aristotle and christianity throws
those away
something might be might be
good but false
you know a lie that we all but the lie
maybe is for our own good
and something might be true but really
harmful and so we've got to deny that
truth
forget about the truth he says
in the old society of christianity
you know that built our entire
civilization
we were we believed that the truth would
set you free
and we believed that lies would enslave
you
and now we believe the opposite
now we believe look at transgenderism i
guess that would be the clearest example
of this we believe that the truth is
cruel that the truth will actually
enslave you if you're a man but you
don't want to be a man that that truth
that you're a man will enslave you and
it's mean and it's nasty and it's wrong
and the lie
the lie say that you are a woman if
you're really a man that the lie will
set you free and some that's what
agrawal's talking about here
and actually you you will see it applied
specifically on this transgender issue
they've already set policies to this
effect at twitter that if you
directly call a man who thinks he's a
woman a man you can be banned for that
doesn't matter that the thing you said
is true maybe it's harmful
because you didn't lie
because lies are good
according to these moral
idiots i don't i don't even say it with
wrath and anger to say that they're
idiots i mean it's just a fact they're
moral idiots and they and it's gonna
harm them in society if they persist you
talk about harmful lies are harmful and
the truth is good and the truth will set
you free cs lewis has a great quote on
this
he says if you look for truth you might
find comfort in the end
but if you look for comfort
you will find neither truth nor comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking to
begin and in the end despair
it is no
mere coincidence
it's no accident
that as our society has discarded truth
and pursued only
a an un
unfettered comfort
that despair has increased
that people are increasingly desperate
they turn to drugs and they turn to
suicide and they turn to all sorts of
madness
got to ground the society and the truth
whether that's on twitter
whether that's in our ordinary
conversations day by day whether that's
our government whether that's the whole
way that we live together
agriwall goes on
he says
our role here at twitter
is not to be bound by the first
amendment
we're going to focus less on thinking
about free speech
and more thinking about how the times
have changed now i know that a lot of
conservatives are going to be really
ticked off by this and they say oh what
a jerk i hate this guy that's terrible
he's he's making
a halfway decent point
in the most defensive and off-putting
way possible but he's saying look at
twitter our standard is not exactly the
first amendment standard
just like in a school a school is not
necessarily bound by the first amendment
the school can say johnny stop saying
that
in the way that the government might not
be able to say
johnny stop saying that right there the
the school
the family
the office place the place of employment
even civic associations can can put more
constraints on speech they can enforce
standards to a greater degree than the
government can
that's always been the case in america
local communities can enforce more of
these standards than the government can
that's long been the case in america
and i think it is fair for agrawal to
say look we're we're a platform we want
our users to have a good experience so
we're not going to allow certain
hateful speech it makes perfect sense
we've always done that
i can't go into a restaurant and just
start screaming whatever i want to
scream
i i might be asked to leave and i i
think it's perfectly legitimate for
twitter to say that to have a similar
kind of standard but what's the standard
going to be
is it going to be that if i tell the
truth if i say perfectly ordinary things
if i say that men are not women if i say
that white people shouldn't all be
genocided
like the twitter space people say they
should be if i say that
actually maybe maybe i want to vote for
donald trump if i say those things
ought to be protected right i think we
just need to as i said in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds makes a great christmas present
number one national bestseller
if i
as i said in this book
we conservatives
need to
move beyond just talking about
procedural norms and just talking about
one
standard view of the first amendment
and pretend that that has always applied
everywhere in society when it hasn't we
need to start talking not just about the
freedom of speech but about what we
ought to say it gets back to the first
part with agrawal on twitter which is we
need to start talking about what's true
and what's good and we need to start
promoting what is true and good and
beautiful
and we need to start opposing and
discouraging things that are ugly and
false
and wicked
speaking of the boundaries of speech you
know my friend lauren beaubert is in
trouble
lauren beaubert freshman congressman
conservative congress congressman
she made a joke about ilhan omar
she made a joke that ilhan omar supports
terrorism and uh
you might not think it's a joke because
ilhan omar has been caught on camera
giggling about al qaeda and hezbollah
but you know it's just a joke she's just
making a joke and you're not allowed to
do that
you're not allowed to make jokes about
the left and you're certainly not
allowed to call them terrorists
you are almost required to call right
wingers terrorists and insurrectionists
and white supremacists and neo-nazis and
whatever
call half the country that
but you're not allowed to make jokes
about the left even
leftists who giggle about al-qaeda so
lauren began to apologize to ilhan omar
i don't think she should have apologized
i'm not against apologies i'm very
pro-apology but in this case i don't
think it was warranted
so she went to apologize i thought that
was a mistake they had a phone call
ilhan omar released this statement about
lauren bobert she goes quote today i
graciously accepted a call from
representative lauren bobert in the hope
of receiving a direct apology for
falsely claiming she met me in an
elevator suggesting i was a terrorist
and for a history of anti-muslim hate
instead of apologizing for her
islamophobic comments and fabricated
lies representative bob refused to
publicly acknowledge her hurtful and
dangerous comments instead she doubled
down on her rhetoric and i decided to
end the unproductive call
i'm glad that lauren stood her grand
cause what lauren did she called
privately apologized and ilhan omar said
no you've got to publicly apologize and
you've got to talk about islamophobia
which is a completely made-up term and
you've got to talk about your
anti-muslim hate which lauren bobert has
not demonstrated and you've got to
you've got to acknowledge your dangerous
comments it hasn't said anything that's
dangerous and
bobert said no i don't think i'm going
to do that
that's the right thing to do here's
here's here's lauren's version of the
conversation
hey everyone this is lauren with a quick
update on a phone call i had today with
squad member ilhan omar i had reached
out to her friday and three days later i
was able to connect with her on the
phone because i wanted to let her know
directly that i had reflected on my
previous remarks now as a strong
christian woman who values faith deeply
i never want anything i say to offend
someone's religion so i told her that
even after i put out a public statement
to that effect she said that she still
wanted a public apology because what i
had done wasn't good enough so i
reiterated to her what i had just said
she kept asking for a public apology so
i told ilhan omar that she should make a
public apology to the american people
for her anti-american anti-semitic
anti-police rhetoric she continued to
press and i continued to press back and
then representative omar hung up on me
love it great stuff
glad lauren did it maybe this was 4d
chess maybe she was just waiting to get
ilhan the whole time but this is exactly
right no reason to apologize for this
joke to ilhan omar whatsoever meanwhile
by the way some of lauren's allegedly
conservative republican colleagues
are going on cnn
to bash her i have time after time
condemned my colleagues on both sides of
the aisle for racist tropes and remarks
that i find disgusting and this is no
different than any others as a member of
congress and seeing such division in our
country
we all have a responsibility both
elected members of congress on both
sides of the aisle and the american
people in our communities and our at
work in our communities and everything
else still lower we have a
responsibility to lower the temperature
and this does not do that i didn't come
to congress uh to throw bombs on twitter
to raise take advantage of people by
saying crazy things to raise money
or to be a comedian i'll leave comedy to
dave chappelle i was disappointed in the
comments i was encouraged to see that
she did apologize for the comments and i
believe that's a step in the right
direction that's republican nancy mace
quote unquote republican nancy mayes
she's in a very conservative district in
south carolina but she's a relatively
liberal republican she is now trying to
codify transgenderism into the into the
federal law into the civil rights act
she refused to sign the amicus brief of
conservatives pushing for the overturn
of roe v wade so she's a lib by
republican standards and i just got to
tell you
i am skeptical of any
any
so-called conservative
who spends her time going on cnn to bash
her conservative colleagues
especially over a joke almost over any
issue but especially over a joke deeply
suspect you didn't come to congress to
attack democrats as she says no you came
to congress to attack fellow republicans
on cnn
not a good look
speaking of the boundaries of speech
another one bites the dust
not just hipster rasputin jack dorsey at
twitter who stepped down apparently
voluntarily or somewhat voluntarily
fredo
fredo cuomo at cnn
was taken out into a fishing boat on the
lake
and he didn't come back metaphorically
speaking
he has been suspended indefinitely from
cnn after a story came out that fredo
advised his brother andrew cuomo who was
you know governor of new york during his
political scandals and cuomo chris cuomo
may have used some of his journalistic
contacts to try to help cuomo here's the
statement from cnn
when chris admitted to us that he had
offered advice to his brother's staff he
broke our rules and we acknowledged that
publicly hold on i just want to pause
right there the way that cnn phrased
this makes it seem like the
transgression was not the wrong doing it
wasn't that he helped his brother and
used his contacts it's that he admitted
the wrong doing right he says when chris
admitted to us that he did this he broke
our rules you're never at cnn the rule
is you never admit wrongdoing so he was
that a freudian slip was that a
freightoen slip i think it might have
been they go on we also appreciated the
unique position he was in and understood
his need to put family first however
these documents point to a greater level
of involvement in his brother's efforts
than we previously knew as a result we
have suspended chris
indefinitely pending further evaluation
this is going to be
maybe an unpopular view on the right but
i've got to say it because it's my view
and i think we ought to put the truth
first
i feel bad for fredo
i feel bad for freda
not because he didn't do anything wrong
he did a lot of things wrong
but i think he's being held to a
different standard here than other cnn
employees
first of all is this the story here the
shocking the big revelation
is that a cnn host a cnn employee
whose brother and father
were both democrat governors of new york
might just possibly be a democrat
operative
no you're stop the presses you're
kidding me what gosh next you're going
to tell me that that bridge that i
bought in brooklyn isn't really mine is
that really you're telling me he is a
democrat
no way
second of all
he's not the first
cnn employee or
establishment media employee to do this
remember donna brazile donna brazile
i think while working for cnn passed
debate questions to hillary clinton
she still works throughout the
establishment media remember
candy crowley remember her she was
moderating a debate between barack obama
and mitt romney and she just lied on
behalf of barack obama to trip up romney
made him lose the debate
based on a complete lie
regarding the benghazi terror attack
remember that
doesn't matter
oopsie daisy whoops moves on
they're they're all democrat operatives
that's what cnn is
cnn is not some impartial
journalistic outlet where facts matter
first no matter what they say it's a
propaganda piece for the left
i don't even really it doesn't even
really bother me in the history of media
generally parties have had their own
outlets the republicans had their
outlets the democrats had their outlet
that's why their newspaper is called the
tennessee democrat right you know and so
i don't i don't really
even mind that i wish they were more
honest about it but
poor fredo
poor fredo i guess that was ever thus
four fredo's he's getting frustrated
he's saying i'm smart
not like everybody says like dumb i'm
smart i can do things
but he can't now because he's been
suspended poor guy all right you know do
you remember i don't mean to belabor the
point on chris chris cuomo but do you
remember during kovid
he got kovid and then he pretended that
he was
he was holding up and quarantining in
his basement
and then he even did that whole thing
where
they filmed him coming up for the first
time and seeing his family and i missed
you and then it was all fake because it
turned out that he was actually going
out for bike rides with his family
during the alleged quarantine out in the
hamptons and the only reason we know
that is because he got into a fight with
some guy on the street and the guy said
hey oh aren't you supposed to be holed
up in your room and he's getting into a
big fight and shouting match so it's all
bs the guy spreads lies on his show
constantly that though doesn't violate
the journalistic integrity of cnn
what violates the journalistic integrity
seriously is that he got caught
that's what does it speaking of getting
caught
you know that the debate over critical
race theory in schools
has largely hinged
on this question is critical race theory
really being taught in schools
the left might say well it's a good
thing well it's a bad thing well i guess
they'll
they'll really just say it's a good
thing
but what a lot of it has come down to is
critical race theory isn't really being
taught in schools
it's just this
legal movement it's only being taught at
harvard law school
you conspiracy theorist conservatives
think it's being taught in elementary
middle and high schools it's not
so we have video
from the detroit superintendent nikolai
viti
saying explicitly
that the detroit public school
curriculum is deeply imbued with
critical race theory
our curriculum is uh deeply using
critical race theory um especially in
social studies but you'll find it uh in
english language arts and the other uh
disciplines we made
we're very intentional about creating a
curriculum infusing materials um and
embedding critical race dear within our
curriculum they're not even shallowly
using critical race theory they're
deeply using it you heard it from
the horse's mouth was that the horse's
mouth i don't know that was some part of
the horse
and actually it's a good explanation of
it
because critical race theory is not it's
not just like
calculus
it's not just like
division or arithmetic it's not just
like you're being taught a lesson okay
this week we're going to learn critical
race theory critical race theory is a
lens
it is an analytical framework through
which you can view just about everything
i also talk about this in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds that critical theory broadly is
not just a system but it's a gadfly on
other academic disciplines right it's
not just one discipline it's it's part
of social studies and literature and
everything and it's there and that's the
reality of it folks and they're going to
lie to you because they don't believe
that truth really matters they don't
think that the truth is necessarily good
they think that some lies can be really
good and some truths can be really
harmful don't let them get away from it
the truth will in fact set you free i'm
michael knowles is the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show